thank you kendall all right southwest
medical is all about preventative care
especially
when it comes to cancer i spoke with one
of their doctors to learn more
unfortunately you've been busy because
everyone has to
keep up with their cancer care correct
absolutely yes it doesn't go away
even with the pandemic right right so
let's talk about um cancer
basics and just you know explain what it
is to everybody
sure okay it's it's a term we throw
around a great deal but it's actually
fairly specific it's a term for diseases
in which
abnormal cells divide without control
and invade
other tissues all cancers start
with one bad cell okay
these cells can spread to other parts of
the body through the bloodstream as well
as through the lymphatic
systems and it may come as a surprise
but it's not just
one disease it's many many many diseases
there are hundreds of types of cancer
really if you subtype them even further
thousands of types and getting screened
regularly
is something that we all can do this
helps find breast cancer cervical cancer
colorectal cancer
and it's at these times early in the
course of a disease
when spread to a more advanced form can
be prevented
and just looking for things where people
are at high risk like
lung cancer amongst certain people can
help
a great deal let's talk more about those
screenings and what types you guys offer
looking at mammograms these are the best
ways to find
breast cancer early
especially when somebody is at high risk
that is with a family history
or when somebody finds a lump or a bump
or something like that
pap test that's done on women looking
for cervical cancer
abnormal cells in the cervix can turn
into
cervical cancer the hpv test
looks for the human papilloma virus on a
dna level and
it's this human papilloma virus that
causes cervical cancer cervical cancer
is almost 100 percent caused
by infection with the human papilloma
virus this is a
sexually transmitted disease people have
to be aware of it
there's a vaccine in fact available for
it looking at colorectal cancer
on the other hand this develops from
pre-cancerous polyps
these are abnormal growths which occur
in the colon erectum
certain people are more prone to develop
them than
others lung cancer screening with a
chest x-ray or more specifically with a
cat scan
is oftentimes recommended for people who
are at high risk
that is people with a
smoking history or certain
exposures exercise is
extremely important keeping one's weight
in a reasonable range is
is very very important that being said
you know even though walking outside and
walking your dog is a great thing to do
particularly in this pandemic i know the
dogs are all tired
and people are getting their exercise
but covering up not getting all that
extra sun exposure using the sunscreens
optim care cancer care has locations
across southern nevada just call 702
702-724-8787 las vegas now we'll be
right back